a lot of great talks about technology
some talks about technology and people
this talk is going to be only about
people so in case the title didn't give
you a clue brace yourselves
um so first let's see who I'm talking to
let's let's have a show of hands raise
your hands if you have in the past say
two years managed or trained a junior
developer okay so about 50% raise your
hand if you have in that time been
unhappy with how your junior was
performing not that many brief brave
people this time okay how many of you
think it's your fault
nice well day you can go um so what I
want you to keep in mind throughout this
talk is that learning is a process that
happens between two sides and both of
these sides are equally responsible for
the success of this process I learned to
code when I was building my startup I
never thought I would be a developer I
came into the startup as the business
person and for reasons that I won't go
into I had to kind of cross over to the
code side and when I started to do it I
realized I really really liked it so
today I'm uh I'm a front-end developer
and I'm also you know I want to say like
I'm very passionate about but I don't
think that's the right word I think the
truth is that I am kind of obsessed with
the question of what keeps people out of
programming and what lets them in so I
do a lot of work around letting people
into programming I volunteer teaching
women how to code I'm now organizing a
hackathon for first-timers
and I guess more than anything I just
talked to a lot of people about it like
all the time so most important thing for
this talk if you guys have any thoughts
on what keeps people out of programming
come find me in the breaks because I
really want to hear what you have to say
and in the weeks leading up to this talk
I spoke to a lot of junior developers
because I wanted to know how did they
learn how did they learn on the job that
they have the same experiences I did did
they have all of them sort of similar
experiences the answer to that question
is no when you asked people how they
learned on the job you will get so many
different answers some people will say
oh I read a really good book
and some people will say I had a mentor
and we did peer programming's or my
mentor sent me really good online
resources or I did an online course or
documentation there's so many ways that
people learn on the job but where you
start to see a theme arise and where it
starts to get interesting is when you
ask junior developers what the person
who taught them could have done
differently if you ask this question you
will start to hear some similar answers
and the thing is that these answers
often don't have anything to do with
teaching methods they have to do with
things that are more intangible they
have to do with things that are more
interpersonal and because they're
intangible and interpersonal junior
developers tend not to bring them up
because it's hard
it requires honesty so after I had all
these conversations I realized this is
not the right angle for this talk this
is not what I should be telling you this
is what I should be telling you I want
to tell you today the
your juniors won't tell you the things
they wished they could particularly six
things that they wish they could tell
you and how you can use them to become
better teachers number one we have no
idea what's about to happen so if you're
in charge of teaching it's probably been
some time since you've been a junior
developer but kind of try and imagine
this with me try and remember your first
day on your first job so you're walking
down the hallway you have never been to
before
maybe you just finished computer science
maybe you learn to code at home on your
own but you've never worked in a company
you've never worked in a team you don't
know what that's going to be like and
you don't know what the code is going to
look like and you don't know what the
people are going to be like you don't
even know what to expect
do you feel how uncertain that feels if
you're in charge of teaching a junior
developer don't be another factor that
adds to their uncertainty and anxiety
there are a lot of things that you can
arrange in advance their seating their
hardware most importantly their schedule
you need to have a plan for your junior
and you need to make sure your junior
knows what that plan is and it can be
anything so if you're having a hard time
coming up with ideas really anything
works can be a tree house course can be
a JavaScript deep dive it can be a
company orientation whatever it is you
need to know what your junior will be
doing for those first few days and then
make sure they know it too so at least
part of their uncertainty is taken away
number two
we don't want to bother you so you've
got a junior on the team and you are
into it right you want to help them you
want them to do well you understand that
if they do well
it's better for the team and you're
committed to teaching them and you have
a plan you want them to learn from the
documentation so when they first come in
that first day you give them a link to
the documentation and you say please
read this and any question you have just
any question come ask me then what do
you do you turn around you go back to
your desk and you sit down to do your
job to work on your code if you have a
problem concentrating what do you do put
on your headphones and you're a junior
is not about to interrupt you and ask
all the questions they have you see
juniors understand that you are there
first and foremost to write code we know
that your job is important and we also
know we feel very distinctly that our
own lack of ability to write code or at
least good code is very obvious so we
know how little we know and at the same
time we really want to do a good job and
the combination of these things it's
gonna make us not want to ask you
questions but if on top of that we also
feel like we're bothering you not gonna
do it so if you're serious about
answering the questions your junior has
set aside a time and a place like really
set aside
I mean schedule it in the calendar
reserve room whatever you have to do and
tell your junior on this day at this
time you will have 30 minutes one hour
to ask me all your questions and I know
this feels like a bit of overhead but
think about this at the end of the day
you want developers who are able to work
together to solve problems who are able
to admit when they don't know some
thing and asking questions is crucial to
these processes so you need to make sure
your junior feels it's really okay that
it's not bothering you and that it
doesn't make us look stupid because the
third thing is as it is we don't think
we're good enough I think if there's one
single most important thing to remember
when you're teaching a junior it's this
your juniors are floundering and
desperately searching google for answers
and we don't even know what answers are
good apart from the Stack Overflow score
so then we might try to implement
something and maybe it works maybe it
doesn't work if it doesn't work we don't
know why right and just generally we
feel like maybe we shouldn't be
programming at all and the thing is
least of all do we want you to know that
this is happening because the worst-case
scenario for us is that you discover
what huge frauds we are and just regret
the day you decided to hire us now this
feeling of feeling like you're not good
enough or that you're a fraud has a name
does anybody know what it's called
impostor syndrome that's right and we
can argue right this is an argument like
do juniors actually suffer from impostor
syndrome or is this just a feeling that
makes sense because it makes sense when
you're starting out to feel like you're
not good enough because you really
aren't that good in the beginning and
that's okay so this feeling is okay the
problem is if it's not managed and if
it's not spoken about it can give rise
to a lot of behaviors that will be
problematic in the beginning and further
down the road because it can't make us
avoid asking questions and it can make
us avoid trying new things for fear that
we might fail and it can make us avoid
telling you when we've made a mistake
anything is we can't do anything about
this because we don't know enough to
gauge our own progress we don't know
enough to evaluate ourselves we need
your evaluation we need your feedback
this is so important as often as you can
give your jr. clear relevant feedback
now two important things about clear
relevant feedback it needs to be clear
and it needs to be relevant how do you
make your feedback clear make sure
whatever it is you're trying to say is
actually understood by the other side if
your idea of criticism is sulking in the
back of the office or if your idea of
praise is looking over a piece of code
and nodding your head you risk your
junior not getting it whatever it is
you're trying to say make sure it makes
it across the table how do you make a
feedback relevant focusing on skills and
outcomes and not on the person really if
you find yourself starting sentences
with the words you are you need to stop
and think about rephrasing them because
when you criticize a person what you're
saying is the person is flawed now if I
as a person I'm not good enough what am
I going to do about that but when you
criticize a skill what you're saying is
the skill is insufficient skills can be
learned they can be improved so make
sure you focus your feedback on these
things that we can control and change
now there's another thing you can do to
sort of help manage these feelings but
you're not gonna like it and it has to
do with sharing similar experiences now
this is a problem because nobody likes
talking about the times when they didn't
feel good enough you don't want to do it
we don't want other people to see our
Kanna says we like to think that we've
always been this good but the thing is
what this does to junior and developers
is that it leaves us feeling really
isolated so not only do we feel like
we're not good enough we also feel like
the only person who has ever not been
good enough in history you could really
do your juniors a huge service by
sharing stories of what it was like for
you starting out now it doesn't have to
be these crazy stories of all your epic
failures it can be just small stuff when
I was just starting out learning to code
and building my first web app do you
remember building your first web app it
felt like anything I tried to do was
just impossible and then a friend who's
a software developer once remarked in
this really casual conversation that he
spends about 50 percent of his time on
Google looking for answers to problems
he's working on for him this was just an
offhand comment but for me it was huge
because it made me realize that what I
was going through was okay and that if I
kept going I would get better so share
with your juniors some of the stories of
the things that happen to you as a
beginner you can really help them out a
lot number four we get bored too we want
to do a good job we want to take the
tasks you give us and do our best at
them and get good results and make you
see that we are a good addition to the
team and we understand that we need to
start small maybe with the more menial
tasks maybe with the jobs other people
don't want to do that's ok everybody's
got to start somewhere but we also don't
love doing the same task over and over
again we also enjoy
challenged in our work maybe that's one
of the reasons we wanted to become
developers in the first place so when
all you have us doing are the same
repetitive tasks again and again we get
bored and what's more is we don't learn
so I'm going to talk about the 10,000
hour rule
I know it's controversial I'm gonna
assume most of you know it but let me
just recap so that we're all on the same
page the 10,000 hour rule states that in
order to become a master at anything you
need to put in 10,000 hours of practice
okay that's what most of us know but
there's actually a second part to that
rule which for some reason gets
mentioned far less often which is you
need to put in 10,000 hours of
deliberate practice deliberate practice
means that at each and every point in
time you're working at a level slightly
higher than you had been before if you
think about it this makes sense right
when you're constantly doing tasks that
are more difficult and complex at the
end of the day you'll be doing the most
complex difficult tasks so when you have
your junior doing the same thing over
and over again you may be sparing them
feelings of frustration and failure
you're probably sparing yourself the
time and energy it would take to walk
them through more complicated tasks but
you're not helping them learn in order
to learn we need to be constantly out of
our comfort zone
we need deliberate practice so make sure
the tasks you give your juniors are
always slightly different or more
difficult than they've had so far now I
think we saw actually an an interesting
example what what I believe could be an
interesting example of this practice
let's talk today when she spoke about
developers not feeling comfortable with
JavaScript because if you have your
juniors doing HTML for the first six
months on the job they're not gonna know
JavaScript
so make sure you give them some of these
more advanced tasks so they learn how to
do them number five we know what you
think of us guys let's just let's just
get it out in the open okay we know
you're sometimes frustrated with us we
know you're sometimes unhappy with how
we're doing we know you don't always
have the time and the energy for us and
our questions and our mistakes and our
breaking things
we understand look it's okay you're
human right you don't always have to be
some paragon of patience thing is we
also know when you think worse stuff
about us we know when you think we're
stupid we know when you think we're lazy
we know when you think we're not cut out
for this and if we see you thinking that
too often we're gonna start thinking it
too see we believe you we don't believe
ourselves we don't trust our own
judgment but we're pretty sure you know
what you're talking about
so if you don't think we can do it we'll
take your word for it
over our own and no it doesn't matter if
you don't tell us what you're thinking
doesn't matter if you don't tell anyone
what you're thinking if you're thinking
it you will communicate it in a million
small ways and we will know and the
truth is I don't believe there's any
good solution to this problem if you
don't believe in someone you shouldn't
be teaching them because if you're
thinking young developers only want
quick fixes all the time
what your junior will learn is that
they're lazy and shallow if you're
thinking women alright no they're just
not as good at solving problems
rationally your junior will learn she's
not a good problem solver if you think
your junior has any inherent quality
that fundamentally prevents them from
becoming a good developer they will
learn that from you and they will do it
faster and more deeply and more
permanently than any coding best
practice I know I've seen this happen so
if you don't believe in the person
you're teaching consider recusing
yourself from that job and passing them
on to someone who has more faith in them
number six we can only be as good as you
are so I'm gonna tell you a story about
a mistake I made at work it was a pretty
big mistake you could say I deleted a
database now when I realized what
happened I just jumped out of my chair
and went running through the office and
tried to find someone who will help me
fix this and it was early in the morning
so most people hadn't arrived and the
one person who was there was the head of
R&D and I was so panicked that I ran
into his room and just said I screwed up
he looked at me and asked what happened
and I told him and he said okay let's
call DevOps and DevOps said he'll be
coming in soon and that he thinks he can
fix this and as far as the head of R&D
was concerned that was okay as far as I
was concerned it was not okay I
didn't know what the system was like and
I didn't know who else could be affected
by what I done and I was generally
horrified
so I sent a message to my team leader
and told him about it and asked him if I
needed to tell anyone else and my team
leader said look DevOps says he's coming
in he thinks he can fix it
let's just wait for him and so I was sat
down back in my chair kind of just
visibly shaking and DevOps came in a few
minutes later I spent the next 30
minutes in agonizing uncertainty and it
turned out he could fix it and it was
okay now some of you are laughing I
don't know if any of you have ever done
this deleted a database but I can't even
begin to describe to you the horror of
that morning I was just sitting there in
my chair thinking how could I have made
such a stupid mistake but at no point in
that time did any of my superiors make
me feel like my mistake was stupid or
inexcusable or going to get me fired
it's one of the most important strongest
lessons I learned about what it means to
be a good developer you shape how we see
the world remember we've never worked
anywhere before we don't have a good
clear mental image of what a developer
can or should be we have you and human
beings learned through copying it's one
of the most natural ways for us to learn
a baby trying to speak is basically
mimicking her parents until she can
create the same sounds they do and this
is not something
we do consciously it just happens it'll
happen throughout our whole life I bet
it happened to you too we learn through
copying we will learn through copying on
the job so if you are one of these
developers who works crazy hours we will
copy you and we will come to believe
that's what makes a good developer if
you are curious and excited about new
technologies we will copy you and we
will come to believe that's what makes a
good developer if you are a team player
we will do that if you are a lone wolf
we will do that whatever you are you
know if you're a harsh critic
if you are adventurous if you're
innovative if you're a robot you kind of
set the limit of what we believe we can
become so think about what you believe
makes a good developer think about what
you want us to be and then be that we
will copy you so I hope I've given you a
bit of insight into what's going on in
your juniors heads I hope you can take
some of these things and implement them
the next time you need to teach someone
and more than anything I hope that when
you go back to work tomorrow you'll try
putting yourselves in the shoes of the
person you're training what would they
tell you you know if they thought they
could tell you anything how can you use
that to become a better teacher remember
I told you I am obsessed with what keeps
people out of programming you are the
gatekeepers you've been given this truly
awesome job of shaping another person so
make
sure you use that wisely now I have a
few more minutes and I did notice that
not everyone here is a senior developer
not everyone here is in charge of
teaching someone else I'm gonna hazard a
guess that there are something junior
developers in the audience where my
juniors had no I I do want to say three
quick things for junior developers to
keep in mind when you're learning on the
job this is not on the presentation I'm
sorry I can add it later if you want to
have it number one work hard
excellence is not something you're born
with
not even excellence in programming it
doesn't matter what people tell you you
know if you have talent and you don't
work at it that's called potential so
make sure you work your hardest to
become the best developer you can become
and to give back to the person on the
other side who is doing their best to
teach you number two it is your job to
learn when I was preparing for this talk
I did a lot of online research I wanted
to see what people were saying about
their experiences teaching on the job
and I found a Stack Overflow thread it
has since then been closed because you
don't talk about that stuff on Stack
Overflow anymore but there was a thread
about it somebody asking how can I teach
my juniors what's the best way and he
got a lot of answers and one of the
answers was from a junior developer
saying my boss doesn't pay me to learn
it got a lot of down votes Junior's your
bosses are paying you to learn it's part
of your job you need to be focused while
you're doing whatever tasks you have to
do you also need to make sure you have
time to get better if you don't have
this time consider walking up to your
boss and boss and asking for it by the
way I think it's a developer's job to
always learn it doesn't matter if you're
a junior or a senior or what stage of
your career you're at you should always
be learning
and then the third thing we talked a bit
about imposter syndrome did you know
there is some something that is the
opposite of imposter syndrome
it's called the dunning-kruger effect I
hope I'm pronouncing that right and what
it is is basically it says that when
you're new to something and you know
very little you end up thinking you know
a lot because you just don't know how
much more there is to know I should have
had a slide with us because I'm doing
the hand gestures so some people that
are beginning actually think they know a
lot because they're just unaware of how
much more there is out there to learn so
if you're a junior developer and you're
sitting in the audience looking at this
presentation kind of thinking now that
doesn't happen to me I don't know you I
don't know how good you are but you
should know that the opposite of the
imposter syndrome also exists thank you
[Applause]
you